while switching gears now april is world
autism month young adults with autism
have one of the lowest rates of
employment among people who have
disabilities even though they are often
high functioning now some have found new
purpose in the intelligence community
thanks to a program that's tapping into
their unique skills to see the world
through a different lens senior
investigative correspondent katherine
herrich has more
as the war unfolds in ukraine
intelligence officials rely on satellite
images to map movements of russian
forces and on analysts in a field where
seeing the world differently has its
advantages it really feels like for the
first time i'm getting to use
the strengths that i have 33 year old
morgan mcardle is a geospatial analyst
at the u.s government's mapping agency
called the nga i'm pretty good at
finding patterns zeroing in on tiny
details like this russian military base
near alaska you could see the
construction of this area over time
mcardle sees the big picture in big data
sets
how big is big
pretty big
in school mcardle struggled for years
not quite fitting in before landing a
position so secret she can't discuss her
portfolio was school tough for you
extremely it was
really difficult for me though early on
mcardle's mother saw her potential she
could read the billboards backwards and
she would do it perfectly
but it wasn't until mcardle's own
ten-year-old son gabriel got diagnosed
with autism
that she began to notice her differences
my mom
was like well your son can't have autism
he's just like you she says you were
surprised
were you surprised i was because she's
so high functioning without good options
to support her son mcardle joined a
small pilot program with four
participants at the nga how has the job
changed your life
it's changed everything about my life i
mean i was on disability for almost 10
years 10 years here mcardle's difference
actually gives her an edge sometimes i
can take what it would take a week for
somebody to do in a couple of hours a
couple of hours
but that's the advantage to being able
to hyper focus a new kind of insight
that the agency's deputy director calls
neurodiversity this is really broadening
that perspective digging into how can
individuals
bring a talent and ability that is
different than others you can notice
patterns of changes in the images
is that easy for you it is well this
tiny little building right here you know
if it expands that's that'll be the
first thing i notice on the next image
you immediately go aha
this has changed right yes that maybe
some of your colleagues don't key in on
it
childhood autism diagnoses have more
than doubled since 2000 and nearly half
of 25 year olds with autism have never
held a paying job
now more families are reaching out to
the intelligence community to learn more
what's it like to get those emails for
me it's touching as a mother i certainly
can understand
wanting the very best for your children
come on bud and broadening the spectrum
of potential it's a lot like finding
where i fit in finally i was looking for
an outlet and it found me i suppose how
does that feel inside oh wonderful the
sky's the limit now i don't feel like
there's anything holding me back
now helping the u.s spy community with a
different kind of intelligence it's a
lot of data to wade through but that's
an advantage to being autistic for cbs
mornings i'm catherine herridge in
martinsburg west virginia
great story talks to you about
possibilities yeah i really like that
everybody has something to offer yes
they really do
what it's worth martinsburg west
virginia not far from where my mom lives
oh hi part of the country all right